[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il va remettre le prix avec ama du
vernet
[Musique]
c'est quelques mots à vous dire ici même
à cannes 23 mai 21 noms de ce festival
était sa chasse gardée a estimé que par
des cris je souhaite prédire qu'il
croyait qu'elle ne sera jamais plus le
bienvenu ici
charlie payne discret la voisine est une
communauté et à toulouse doit même ceux
qui n'ont jamais dénoncé ces faits et
famille atomiques actives on devrait
pointer de toit à cause de leur
comportement envers les fans depuis un
comportement indigne dans cette
industrie
un digne de n'importe quelle industrie
vous savez qui vous attaquent les plus
importants ou encore nous nous savons
quand on parle de galloway nous n'allons
pas vous permettre de vivre dans
l'impunité
[Applaudissements]